[Singing]
I grew up in a little Baptist Church
called Mills Chapel Baptist Church and
it was right beside the house that I
grew up in, so I tell everybody, every
time the church doors opened, I was there
because there was nothing else to do
but go to church.
Dr. Jill Hamilton has come a long
way as a nursing professor and researcher,
but her heart has never strayed far
from Black Mountain, North Carolina,
where the grandmother who raised her with church and song championed her ambition to go to college.
"My grandmother used to always say to me,
'I couldn't go, but you gonna go.' She'd
always brag on me, and you know she was
always encouraging, and so I think what
motivates me now to really do what I do,
do the research that I ] do, do the nursing
care that I do for the population is
because I used to always say, 'I want to
do something to give back to people like my grandmama.'
So my passion even today is with the
care of older and African Americans.
Because when I give back to
them, I'm giving back to my grandmama."
Hamilton's most recent study intends to
demonstrate that positive health
outcomes for African Americans with
serious diseases like cancer can be
buoyed by religious comforts like
favorite songs or Bible verses.
"When a patient first comes in, part of the
assessment should be, 'Do you have a song
or Bible verse that you use when you are
stressed, when you're worried, when you're
nervous, when you're anxious?' and we
should document that in the chart."
Hamilton has amassed a database of
several dozen, recordings showing people
reciting a prayer, Bible verse, or singing
a song of comfort. She plans on sharing
the scenes with willing patients as part
of a forthcoming study that will try and
find out to what degree this type of
spiritual therapy can aid the healing process.
But when Hamilton began her work conventional wisdom was not on her side.
"They said, 'What else was published?'
and I would say, 'Well, we're gonna change that!'
But at the time this was like in
1997, when I first started doing my
dissertation research, and it was
absolutely forbidden just to talk about
God in healthcare. I was told, 'No, you can't
do that,' but I kept doing it anyway
because that's what people that
was what was important to the population.
We think of social support coming from a
spouse, from a friend, from a family member,
and yes, African Americans have that also, but
for African Americans, and I'm sure for
other racial ethnic groups as well,
but particularly for older African Americans,
they have come to rely on God as a
source of support, and you can't ignore
that,  you can't separate it, because
God is as real in their network of support as any
other close relative that we can actually see."
Cory Woodyatt is a student of Hamilton's
who got the notion to try out her approach
during one of his clinical rotations.
"The ER was busy. There was a lot of people,
there was a long line up for folks to
get in and we received a new patient
who came into the main ED with his wife."
The patient was impaired and agitated, and so it was
difficult for the medical staff to help him.
"He was getting a lot more anxious
and he was shaking and he was trying to
get out of the bed, and he was getting
more confused, so I pulled out my cell
phone and I put on 'Amazing Grace.'  The moment that the song came on he calmed right down."
"Perceptions have changed about spirituality
and now we realize
that is a very important part of health care.